hello everyone welcome today's live
broadcasts dissecting the diagnostic
yield of exome sequencing I'm Bob
Woodard and i'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I have a
couple of important announcements this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to submit questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them into the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the left thank you I would now
like to introduce today's speaker Deanna
church dr. church is the senior director
of genomics and content at personalis
incorporated a clinical genome
diagnostics company located minimal Park
California please join me in welcoming
dr. church I will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you Bob
and I'd like to thank everyone for
taking time to join today to listen to
this presentation and first of all I
would like to start off by thinking
several of the individuals who have
either contributed data to this
presentation or contributed very
important ideas in terms of thinking
about how we improve our process and the
kinds of experiments that we want to do
I'd also like to give you a little more
background about who we are so as Bob
mentioned we're a small of clinical
diagnostics company located in Menlo
Park California and we actually offer
services in both inherited disease
Diagnostics as well as in cancer and
general research services and we can
offer these services either on research
basis or in our CLIA and cap accredited
laboratory and what's important to
remember about all of these products is
they
set on top of what we call our ace
platform and so the ACE platform is
really designed to help us solve key
accuracy issues that we observed in the
genomics diagnostic space and what this
really means is we've sort of broken
down the process of sequencing the
informatics the annotation and the
interpretation try to identify key
problematic areas in each of these
regions and try to improve those to
build an integrated platform to improve
diagnostic yield and accuracy so when we
think about that you know there's a lot
of different things that we think about
that go into each of these steps but
today I'm going to focus on four key
areas first we're going to talk a little
bit about assay development we're then
going to talk about how we might I say
how is how that assay is performing
we're going to talk about the importance
of variant identification and accurate
variant identification as well as the
annotation of those variants once we
have identified them but before we
actually start talking about these four
areas I'd like to take a step back and
really sort of explain what we think and
what we mean by diagnostic yield because
it a little bit different they came out
this in a clinical setting versus a
research setting and so when we think
about diagnostic yield what we're really
thinking about as what variants can we
return to an order in position to help
them informed patient care so this is
not just an interesting variant that we
might find that looks like it could be
causative or looks like it may be
involved in disease we really think
there has to be very strong evidence to
support this case and this evidence is
really predicated by guidelines from
resources such as the American College
of medical genetics and in this next
slide while I'm showing you is this
matrix of evidence that they've put
together that allow us to come up with
criteria by which we can define whether
a variant is likely to be packaged enok
and affecting a patient's disease or not
so I think you know it's very important
to think about the complexity of this
process but it's also important for us
to think about the fact that the idea of
genomic testing
is not new and so one of the things that
we also want to think about is what kind
of diagnostic yield should we be
expecting and so this is just to remind
everyone that we've really been doing
genomic based Diagnostics since we could
identify chromosomes under a microscope
and really the first test we could start
developing when we realized that an
additional chromosome 21 lets down
syndrome and for many many years
karyotyping was the first line genomic
tests that were performed on individuals
that presented with generalized
developmental delay and in general the
diagnostic yield on this test is roughly
three to five percent now as technology
improves and becomes more precise what
we can see is a moderate increase in
that diagnostic yield so as molecular
technology such as fish were developed
where we could probe specific areas of
the genome we saw an increase in the
diagnostic yield and then as technology
improved and we begin to enter the
genome area we could do more and more
precise test again leading to an
increase in diagnostic yield so here we
see using techniques such as a CGH array
either back arrays or I'll ago arrays
which are more in practice now we can
see an additional increase in diagnostic
yield although again these are these are
typically identifying relatively large
event as opposed to you know single
nucleotide variants now while many of
these large-scale genomic techniques
were being developed there was also what
I often referred to as a sort of Golden
Age of positional cloning so really
prior to the availability of a reference
assembly we were able to do positional
cloning and identify variants in genes
leading to very common Mendelian
diseases and so this just shows a
timeline of the identification of some
of these disorders and so as the
variance and disease associations were
being made genetic testing were that was
actually developed to go alongside of
this and in much of this happened really
well before we had a well-developed
reference assembly and could do
large-scale sequencing which has led to
the to the type of testing that is still
very common today which is the notion of
doing either single gene
one saying are now more commonly gene
panels which may sa five to twenty to
several hundred genes that may be
associated with a specific phenotype
respect remove phenotypes and so if we
want to really look at what the
diagnostic yield and gene panels are one
of the things that we see is in fact
that this diagnostic yield varies wildly
so we see on the low end the diagnostic
yield may be as low as ten percent and
on the high end it starts to approach a
hundred percent and the two things that
really affect how what your diagnostic
yield will be are the specificity of the
phenotype so how specific of phenotype
you have on that individual and what is
the genetic heterogeneity of the disease
that is how many genes may lead to that
phenotype when they were disrupted and
so we can see there's really quite a
yield depending upon that now what we
don't often think about in terms of
thinking about this diagnostic yield but
clearly also affect our ability to do a
gene Disease Association are things like
reduced penetrants or variable X for a
sunni so when we want to start looking
at things like exome sequencing and
understand what the diagnostic yield in
that realm is what I can show you here
is the diagnostic yield that we see in
our own laboratory so currently when
we'd perform a clinical exome test we
are able to return a result to a
position approximately forty-eight
percent of the time now to compare to
recently published work on 2000 exomes
we see that on average the diagnostic
yield there is about twenty-five percent
and a recent paper actually looking at
mouse strains should a diagnostic yield
about fifty three percent although I
think this is an interesting case
because in the example of the mouse
study in many cases they had identified
the area of the genome in which they
were interested in looking so they were
able to reduce their search space which
is very helpful in terms of trying to
identify what you're what you're looking
for if we look more carefully at the
breakdown of this I think it's also
important to remember that when we think
about something that we return to a
position if not necessarily the case
that every very return has a clinical
assertion of pathogenicity so we can see
an over sixty-five percent of the time
that is in fact we return something this
Oh genic or likely pathogenic that's in
a gene that is well associated with the
phenotype so this is a really strong
case but then there are other cases
where we want to return a gene variant
of uncertain significance and it may be
in a gene in which there's a very good
association between Jean de phenotype
but we may be uncertain of what the
effectiveness variant is in other cases
we might see a case where the individual
gives us an unusual presentation of a
disorder so what we might be seeing is
an expanded phenotypic spectrum of this
disorder in other cases we have seen
that we've seen individuals where we
think there's reduced penetrance and
then lastly and this is a very common
thing in the exome field as we are also
now able to ask a more of the genome
than half before as we might return
varies in what we consider an emerging
disease area and what this means is that
there are less than three families that
provide evidence for this genius Disease
Association so maybe not as strong and
evidence as we might like but surely but
clearly subjective so we think these are
pretty strong criteria for returning to
physicians but one of the things that we
really want to focus on is how do we
reduce this negative number because what
we really would like to be able to do is
give these positions very informative
information so they can have a positive
impact on their patients outcomes and so
what the rest of the talk I'm going to
focus on how we think about reducing
that negative number by increasing
accuracy and so the first thing I'll
talk about is our approach to assay
development now typically when I start
talking about this people often start
having an argument about well really
should you be doing genomes in a
clinical setting or should you be doing
exomes in clinical setting and then that
also turns to well should you be doing
panels in a clinical setting or should
he be doing exomes in a clinical setting
and people have very very strong
opinions about this and we'll have what
are almost religious type arguments
about which of these assays is better
but i would actually assert to you that
these are not actual specific assays but
rather you know whether you're using the
term whole genome or whole exome or
panel these are really umbrella terms
for an essay so in this slide
demonstrate what I'm thinking about here
which is so in this area up here what we
have is the genome sort of boxed out in
different types of annotated regions
that you might be interested in subsea
DSS and utrs other regions of the genome
that might be interpreted biologically
annotated regions and then the rest of
the genome that we don't really have a
good idea of what's going on obviously
not drawn to scale and so classically
especially as this high-throughput load
cost sequencing was developed people
would consider a whole genome something
that assessed all of these regions
although we know in fact the visit that
that we can't have access to the entire
genome and then the classic exone when
there was really only one or two
products in the in the world really
focus largely on the coding sequences
and then we still have our classical
singer panels which was really focused
on assessing the coding sequence of a
very small number of genes with a strong
association to a phenotype but as we've
learned more about doing this kind of
analysis we've actually expanded our
range of products and approaches to
trying to assay the genome and so now
there are many products out there
labeled exone that actually cover both
the cdss and the utrs additionally we've
now moved into the realm of what we call
the Augmented etc and what we really
mean by that is we're actually not
really just targeting the exonic areas
we're really trying to identify what we
would consider the medically
interpretable part of the genome to try
and I say that with very high fidelity
and you can think about doing that both
at the exone level as well as the panel
level and so what I would really
encourage you to think about is that you
don't want to think about an essay as
being whole genome or whole exome but
you really want to understand the
specifics of that essay and you really
want to understand the question it is
that you want to ask so in many cases it
might be very important for you to ask a
the whole genome and so you want
something that's going to try and do
that whereas in other cases you might
want to make sure that you're covering
specific parts of the genome with very
high fidelity and confidence
that's what you really care about so you
really need to understand the
performance of your assay so our
approach has actually been focused on
trying to identify we would consider the
medically important part of genome and
we do this by having a complex
integration system from a lot of
different resources to identify variants
and genes that might be important
Mendelian disease or cancer or
pharmacogenomics to try and make sure
that we can SATs with high fidelity we
then take what might be considered a
standard exome and we augment that to
make sure that we can cover these
medically important regions as
demonstrated by the additional green
probes that we might add to make sure
that we cover regions both that are
important in medically important genes
as well as regions outside of those
jeans we've taken a similar approach
with our cancer platform which has been
able to build upon this approach of
really targeting the specific regions of
the genome that we want to look at by
also developing tumor assays that allow
us to assay specific fusion events or
specific RNA events that allow us to
provide a better out information for
people in the cancer diagnostic space so
we've talked a little bit about how you
might think about developing an assay
and thinking about an acetate but now
once you pick the assay that you want to
use for your clinical or research
question you really need a good way to
assess the performance of that essay now
one metric and it's certainly not the
only metric but one metric that we use
is what we consider gene finishing or
coverage now one of the the terms that
you might hear consistently is that we
sequence this genome at 120 X or erath
is X I'm 120 X with this genome at 30 X
and what that really means is on average
every base that was targeted is sequence
direct to that coverage but in practice
that's not really what happens because
what we can see here this is 30 X whole
genome sequencing and what I'm showing
you is a coverage plot so what we've
done in the x-axis is we've removed the
introns from the gene
we're just showing the exonic regions of
the gene in dark blue we're showing a
standard deviation below average and in
light blue it's a standard deviation
above average and so what we can see is
actually wild variability so even though
on average this genome was covered at 30
X we see regions and these medically
important genes that either have no
coverage or they might have wildly
variable coverage so they perform very
different from asking to assay until if
you're in a clinical setting and you
want to make sure that you're covering
clinically important genes fully then
you need to do something to help improve
this outcome I think another important
thing in terms of thinking about what a
say you're looking at is really
understanding how these different assays
perform using this metric and so what we
show here is on the x-axis we're showing
the percent basis with greater than 20 X
local coverage and that's for Q 20 basis
and on the y-axis we're showing percent
finished exons and what we're really
looking here at a roughly the 8000 what
we would consider medically
interpretable genes and here we have the
labels for each of these assays now one
of the things that I hope is is clear to
people is that we have several assays
here that would be labeled an exome that
are all uniformly performing better than
a whole genome using this particular
metric metric of coverage and another
exone that is also performing better
than whole genome at this very high end
of looking at one hundred percent
coverage but the other thing that's
important is all these things that are
labeled XO also have very different
performance characteristics and this is
why it's really important when you're
looking at the assay that you want to
use for your clinical or research
question that you understand the
performance metrics of that assay and
understand how you want to assess that
this is sort of another way of looking
at this problem and this is data that we
were gotten from rachel gould veteran
you in ashley's laugh or she's been
really specifically looking at the ACMG
genes so this is a list of genes for
which the ACMG recommends reporting
secondary
findings when you're doing an exome
analysis on a patient and so these are
considered very important medical gene
that say you would want to make sure
that you have very good coverage of
these genes and so what we show here is
a personality xxo at a bailar a sec zone
as well as two different whole genome
analysis and what you can see is that as
you go down this list the number of
bases that might be missed in these
assays continues to grow I think this is
a pretty important thing to look at as
well and that two essays that are
nominally considered whole genome assays
can still have very different
performance characteristics and so just
saying that somebody is doing whole
genome sequencing or whole exome
sequencing is just not sufficient
understanding how you're covering the
content of that you care about is what's
really important regardless of the assay
type that you choose so why do we think
this is important so we've seen examples
of this in our own clinical lab and so
I'll walk you through a case very
briefly that we worked on here and so
this was a case of a family with two
sons that presented was infantile on set
right not his pigmentosa they had high
myopia and there was no family history
of this now the head had prior gene
testing so 13 gene autosomal recessive
retinitis pigmentosa family so they were
sent to us for exome sequencing and so
one of the things that's very
interesting in this case is that we know
that approximately eighty percent of
x-linked retinitis pigmentosa is caused
by mutations in the RPG our gene and so
what I show here again is this coverage
plot that I showed you earlier so here
we see coverage using a standard exone
and this is on average the red line here
represents 20 x coverage the dark blue
again shows one standard deviation below
the mean and this is just a
representation of the gene RPG or three
and below that and so what you can see
in the red circles are regions where you
either have no coverage or where you
have highly variable coverage now one of
them is
misconceptions I think that people think
about in terms of genome sequencing is
that if you have regions and aren't well
covered and say 30x that all you really
need to do is sequence hires try and get
those coverage and that's absolutely not
true so here is the same gene and same
coverage plot but now it's been sequence
to well over 100 x coverage and what you
can hopefully see is that the same
problematic regions are still not
covered well and the reason for this is
that this lack of coverage is not due to
just to cast it variation but there is
actually genomic architecture here that
makes assessment of this region
problematic and this is where our
approach doing specific assay
development can help fill in these
regions and so when we look at
performance of this gene using the A's
exome what we can see is now these
regions that are not well covered in the
standard exone now are very well covered
in the Augmented x zone and this becomes
even more important when we see look at
our patient with a variant exactly in
this region and this is in fact where
most of the causative variants for RPG
our cluster so being able to cover this
region with high fidelity is really
critical to understanding the influence
of RPG are in retinitis pigmentosa and
how these might affect patient outcomes
so next I'm going to talk a little bit
about actual variant identification so
you've got good assay development and
you and you're doing your sequencing and
now we need to think about varying
identification and how we're going to
call these variants so one thing that I
tend to think about a lot it's not just
the algorithms for doing the alignments
of the calling but really how does the
reference assembly influence your
ability to identify variants so I'm
showing you here is a cartoon example
where we have a sample that has g1 and
g2 but our reference assembly so the
assembly that we're going to use for
analysis only contains gene one now the
way that most people tend to think about
this is well I'll be able to analyze
gene one but I might not be able to
analyze gene
and I think the problem with that is
that that is actually the best case
scenario because if Jean two is related
to Jean one anyway you might start
seeing reads that are derived from this
gene to locust recruited and aligned to
the gene one locus and your references
simply now it fit this concern ibly to
two different outcomes so if these
alignments really become very messy what
it may mean is that you just don't call
any variance in this region because your
aligners and variant callers are just
going to throw up their hands they're
not going to know what to do with the
alignments however if Jean two is really
highly related to gene one what you
might start seeing is that you might
start making variant calls based on the
alignment of the blue reads not the
green reads leading to false positive
variant calls because what you're
actually identifying our all August
sequence differences between g1 and g2
rather than the allelic variation
between the two copies of gene word that
you're interested in we know that this
is more than a theoretical observation
so we have taken sequence that we know
was not present in gr CH 37 which was
the previous version of the reference
assembly and probably the version of the
reference assembly that most people are
still using so we took these novel
sequences decomposed these into reads
and then we align those back to gr CH 37
and we did this using four different
alignment methods and what we saw was
that really only about a third of the
reeds did not align to the reference
assembly in this case but in fact about
two-thirds of them regardless of the
alignment method found in off target
alignment suggesting the importance of
the reference assembly and getting
accurate alignments thus and improved
variant calls so now with that being
said we'll also talk a little bit about
gr CH 38 I know this is a this is the
more recent version of the reference
assembly and and something that often
strikes fear in the heart of many
because trying to transform for one
reference assembly from to another can
be quite challenging but I think it's
instructive to sort of think about some
of the differences between gr CH 37 and
jeer
eh 38 and then later on I'll also talk
to you a little bit about how we might
be able to use some of the information
in gr CH 38 to inform our analysis of 37
while we work on that transition but
I'll just walk you through one example
that sort of exemplifies some of the
difficulties in using gr CH 38 and some
of the things that we fix that were
problems in gr CH 37 and so this is a
region on chromosome 17 contains the
gene family ccl3 and these blue lines
represent the clone tiling path that was
used to construct the chromosome
assembly here so we can see this region
right here contained a large gap this
track here alright this track here are
gene annotation this truck here is
clinvar in this truck here it's DV snip
so one of the things that we learned
from research from other groups is that
did you note the genomic organization of
this region in gr CH 37 probably doesn't
exist in any one because there's a known
probably more visit in this region such
that an individual can have 0 to 4
copies of a 90 kb repeat so this gap
that we see here is actually false gap
and we have two different alleles in
series and when we zoom in so this box
highlights part of the G family here
understanding getting the genotype of
this region right is important because
there have been some associations
although these are a little bit
controversial right now the possibly
copy number of genes in this region
might affect your ability to become
infected with HIV now I would assert
that perhaps one of the reasons that the
association here is somewhat
controversial is that if you want to do
genotype to phenotype associations it's
really important to get the genotype
correct and we have not done that in
this case I'm sure that's leading to
some confounding problems in the
analysis so what we were able to do was
take advantage of the availability of
haplotype resource derived from a high
data form mold so high guetta for mole
is the product of conception when a
sperm fertilizes an enucleated egg
there's several rounds of cell division
leading to a molar pregnancy which is
been terminated but that resource now is
based on a single sperm and as a single
haplotype so this sequel haplotype
resource we have chm one has been well
described in this publication by
Steinberg it out but it's also been a
very valuable resource because in
addition to having whole genome data
from this resource we also have back
data and we were able to take
complicated regions such as the CCL
region and actually build a back tiling
path that we know is based on one single
haplotype and when we did that we we
learned that the CH of one resource had
a complete deletion of we love this
region and we thought that was
unfortunate and wanted to at least be
able to represent one representation of
the insertion and so we actually had
availability of that from the original
donor and the original assembly and so
what I'm showing you here is what we
call an alternate locus so this is an
alternate representation of the CCL
three region it's represented is this
roughly 325 KD contig and what I'm
showing you here is this sequence with
its gene annotation and an alignment to
chromosome 17 so in these alignment
pictures where you see complete grey
like this there's a perfect match these
red lines indicate mismatches and this
thin line is a region where there is no
alignment so this region here
demonstrates see sequence that is
available only on the ultimate locus and
not on the chromosome assembly and so
just to put this more in global
perspective these purple triangles show
regions in the genome for which these
alternate sequence representations are
available and so what this really means
is there is still a chromosome assembly
and while some of the chromosomes may
have
gaps we have sequence you know from the
from the teal America telomere with gaps
included but regions where there's
excessive diversity there might be an
additional sequence that has been
instantiated as a fast a sequence and
then aligned back to the chromosome that
it's also available for analysis and so
when you collectively look at all of
these green triangles what we see is
that there is 3.6 mega bases of sequence
in these alternate low side that is not
available in the chromosome sequence and
there's a hundred and fifty three unique
genes this graph here shows the amount
of unique sequence / alternate locus so
what this shows is that these are
actually not homogeneous at all the vast
majority of the alternate lo sai
contribute less than 50 kb of unique
sequence but some of them contribute all
the way out to 350 kb of unique sequence
so these are very important and diverse
sequences that are adding additional
diversity that allow us to represent
better the human population but there's
a lot of difficulty in using these
sequences and so I have a couple of
examples just to show you here and a lot
of this has to do with the algorithms
that have been developed for doing
genome analysis because these algorithms
have largely been developed based on the
notion that the reference assembly is
represented by a single haploid
representation and so if you end up with
a sequence read like these reeds and
purple here that allow you to more than
one location the math quality of these
reeds is going to be priests and that is
rightfully so because we actually don't
know which of these low sigh this Reed
arrives from but now when we introduce
the concept of an alt locus so here I
show a cartoon of an alt locus align
back to the chromosome sequence and here
we see the unique sequence now we see
this read which is unique with respect
to the primary now also has a secondary
location and so most of our reader
liners that have been tuned to try and
down math
or down that quality reads derived from
/ Oleg asleep duplicated sequence cannot
distinguish now this pyrolysis
duplication from the allelic duplication
that's introduced by multilocus and so
there is a significant need for tool
development in order to allow us to take
full advantage of the gr CH 38 assembly
i would say additionally there are
challenges with variant representation
so if we if we do have alignments that
we can interpret to the primary and the
ultimate locus most of the very common
tools are also expecting a haploid
reference and so if there is a
difference between your read which may
be a C and your alt locus which may be a
G there's likely going to be a genotype
call of 11 because they're going to be
called homozygous with respect to the
alternate locus when in fact a variant
at the alternate locus could be
hemizygous if your sample contains both
the rep sequence representation found on
the primary as well as a sequence
representation found on the alt so it
really underscores the importance of
being able to go back in and do really
pretty robust genotype reconstruction of
your sample in order to really robustly
characterize some of these very very
complex regions that we have in our
genome now I hope many of you have heard
of the global alignments and this move
towards trying to have a graph-based
representation and so what this means is
instead of having this flat happily
representation we can actually take all
of the variation we know about and
represent it in a single structure and
have access to this at all one time and
there are a lot of really you know
really smart people working on this but
it's going to take a little bit of
effort and time to build up in both the
data models as well as the
infrastructure and tools to use these
structures and I would assert in fact
that thinking about approaches that
allow us to use the alternate lows I as
they exist in gr CH 38 today become
important and I'll demonstrate that with
this one relatively simple slide where
all I did was I took all the genes
annotated
the NCBI annotation 105 and I looked and
I said well how many of those jeans
overlap an alternate locus and that
number is roughly five percent but if I
just look at the medically interpretable
gene so the roughly twenty-five percent
that we consider medically relevant we
actually now see about 6.4 percent of
those genes are in these regions where
there's alternate low side so this
really underscores the fact that these
regions where there's extreme complexity
and diversity are not medically
uninteresting at all and in fact they
contain many medically relevant genes
such as the MHC or the Kiera locus so
one approach that we take in to try and
investigate this and see if there's a
way that we can get access to some of
the new data and 38 is to use sequences
that the GRC release that are called
fixed patches and so this again
underscores the thing I'm going to talk
to you about now are not in production
these are just sort of research that we
have been doing on the side to see how
improving the reference is simply
improves your ability to do variant
calls and this carry a typical tation
all of the orange dots that you see our
region's worth GRC released a fix patch
so operationally this looks like an out
locus so they just release a Content
sequence that aligns back to the
chromosome except rather than
representing diversity like what you see
in the novel patches in the out loves I
these represent regions where the
underlying chromosome assembly is
incorrect and the fixed patch provides a
correct representation of that region
and so the approach that we take is as
follows so what I show here this blue
line represents a fixed patch at the
shank to locust so shake too is a
medically important gene thought to be
associated with autism and again I show
you another alignment track so we see
this is the alignment to chromosome 11
where the shank 2 gene is and we can see
for the most part this is a very good
alignment there are no miss
matches but what we do see here is this
one little poor region and this is a
region where there is no sequence of the
chromosome representation but we have
sequins on this fixed patch and this
sequence actually contains two coding
exons so if you are using gr CH 37 and
you're trying to analyze shake too
you're actually missing these two coding
exons that you only have access to
either in gr CH 38 or by using the fix
patch so the approach that we take
here's the chromosome representation
here is the fixed patch representation
and we can just relax the chromosome
representation so we force reads to
align to the fix patch and this gets us
around this problem of the allelic
duplication that's introduced by these
alternate sequences we can then take
this data and do alignment and read
colon and so what I'm showing you here
are normalized read plots so we expect
the reeds to be right around one and we
show at the top alignment to a fixed
patch and at the bottom alignment to HS
3075 or the thousand genomes version of
the reference assembly and so not
surprisingly there is no sequence
alignment here and we see a nice
sequence alignment here so getting
better alignments in a region of a
six-pack i think is not too surprising
but what we can really see that's very
exciting is when we look outside of the
regions of fixed patches we can see in
generalized improvements so here I'm
also showing you a normalized read plot
but in this case we have both plotted on
the st. plot the dark blue is from HS 37
v5 and the green is the fixed patch
version of the reference assembly and so
what we see as we go from something that
looks a lot like a duplication in fact
to a nice normalized plot when we go in
and look at the igb plot for this what
we see when we look at HS 37 v5 is we
see a region with lots of diversity much
much more than we would expect and many
of these are heterozygous calls when we
now look at this in the fixed patch
version what we see is now in much
cleaner alignment with a much more
expected
representation of snips most of which
are homozygous so we can find 378 such
regions where we see a greater than 10
SMB difference between these two calls
now this is not just a one-off although
so we can find other regions where we go
from HS 3075 relatively messy-looking
igb plots to relatively clean expected
snip diversity but it's not all rainbows
and sunshine so we do see regions in
this case where we go from a pretty
messy region with excessive variation in
HS 3075 to a different representation of
excessive variation and excessive
heterozygous calls and 30 7 p-10 so this
really goes to show that we have more
work to do but it does underscore the
importance that the reference assembly
can have in making accurate variant
calls now again we can see the
importance of really being able to
perform accurate variant calls when we
look at some of the cases that we've
seen in our lab so in this case we had a
family come in with a couple of affected
kids with intellectual disability and
some related phenotypes and when we
sequence them we actually found that the
two offspring had the same variant and
guaranteed a daddy to be but when we
looked at the gatk genotypes we saw the
same very in the father that's an
unaffected father so leading us to
believe if we had not looked at this
morning deeply that this was not a good
variant for this case but when we were
investigating the variant further you
know Gannon dtb was a very good
candidate for for being related in this
family's disease and the variant that we
found in our family clusters with other
variants that have been seen in this
other disease causing various symptoms
Ian seen in this disease so he looked a
little bit more closely and what we
found was that even though gatk had
determined that the father of genotype
was heterozygous when we looked at the
allele ratio what we can see is that
this is way off of what we would expect
so we can see the two children that have
a
much more expected allele ratio for a
heterozygous variant and the father was
much lower leading us to suspect that in
fact what the father has a mosaic
variant rather than follow Alec when we
went in and sinker validated this and I
apologize for the transformation problem
here we could actually see because this
is an insertion we can actually see the
ghosts of the offsets and allowed to
allow us to confirm that the father was
indeed mosaic now I think this
underscores both the importance of
having very deep sequencing and very
accurate sequencing for being able to
identify these very low frequency events
and it's becoming very interesting in
the Mendelian feel to really actually
look at the effect of mosaicism and how
often mosaicism may actually play a part
in in these disorders so lastly I'm
going to talk a little bit about variant
annotation and so one of the things that
we have been looking at doing is
understanding if we can use grch 38 to
inform our analysis of gr CH 37 and so
in order to do this we just aligned it
to assemblies together using and we
using the NCBI approach for this and so
I want to introduce you to the concept
of two different kinds of alignments
when we do these assembly assembly
alignments one of which is what we call
a first pass alignment and these are
cases where you get essentially a
reciprocal best hit so these are
relatively you this is a relatively
unique region in the two assemblies this
would be considered a reciprocal best
hit we then go back and we look for
regions that are unaligned in each
assembly to see if we can find a good
alignment and in this case where we see
a repeat that is expanded in assembly
one that's not represented in assembly
to we can recover this alignment and so
when we think about this if we see a
signature where we have a second pass
only alignment and assembly that's
really a signature for an expansion so
we can see if an expanded related
sequence in this assembly whereas if we
see both a first pass and effective pass
alignment this is a signature for
collapse in business
now I want to remind everybody that the
notion of either collapse or expansion
is really not a qualitative term because
when we look at the analysis of this of
GRC their age 37 and gr CH 38 so 38 is
in green 37 is in blue we actually see
regions in 37 or excuse me in regions of
38 that look like they are collapse we
know this is not surprising because we
know one of the main problem 237 was
happy to pick expansion so we would have
regions where we might represent two
three or four alleles and series because
structural variation the region confound
it assembly but it's quite clear that
the picture is actually dominated by
collapse and 37 so what this suggested
was that there was several there's a
large amount of sequence that was
missing in 37 but that sequence was
related to sequences and other sequences
in 37 so these are largely what we
considered missing paralogs we can
actually use these alignments to try and
project the location of features and 37
on to 38 and so I have done this with
several commonly used variant sets and
what I want to focus on is the fact that
we can identify several thousand of
these variants that map to these regions
of collapse most importantly I'd like to
focus on the variants from Clinton bar
where we see 278 variants in clinvar and
this is from a version of clinvar last
year that mapped these regions of
collapse and in this data set about 88
of these were had an assertion of
pathogenic so we'll look at one specific
example here we're going to focus on the
KC in one gene so up top we have gr CH
37 down below we have gr CH 38 here we
have the gene track here we have a
alignment paralogous sequences we have
our clinvar track and then we have
predicted peraga sequence variants and
then tracks are the same in both 37 and
38 in this diagram so it's a couple of
things to note so number one the gene
model is actually very different between
37
38 is represented by this gray box
showing an extended utr and 37 it's not
available in 38 so not only do you have
to think about transitioning coordinates
you do have to pay attention to the
transcript representations but luckily
all of our pathogenic variants here are
in this exon that is same between both
versions of the assembly but what we
actually see in 38 is now the addition
of a paralogs that was missing in 37 if
we zoom in more closely on this what we
see here is the parent Casey and one
gene this is the gene representation
this is the alignment to the prerogative
sequence here we have clinvar variants
and and purple on this track means the
clinvar very is pathogenic here we have
a predicted parraga sequence variant and
this predicted peraga sequence variant
exactly overlaps a predicted pathogenic
variant in kc anyone so I think this is
an interesting annotation that can think
about now adding to this variant because
we really need to go back and understand
the analytical validity and understand
how these variants were called which is
somewhat problematic because most of the
variants of DD snip we don't really have
the evidence for but we want to go back
and do due diligence to make sure any
variant calls in this region are
actually a wheelie and not paralogous as
this region is prone to identifying
crawling the sequence variants lastly
I'm going to talk a little bit about
variant representation because it's not
just being able to annotate card at the
part of the issue of annotating a
variant is being able to match it to
other variants that you've seen before
and there are two problems with this one
of which is that there are multiple ways
to represent a variant in a VCF file so
VCF is the common genetics structure
used to represent variants in when
you're doing large-scale genome analysis
and this figure is taken from a recent
paper from Adrienne tan and his
colleagues showing how the same variant
can have multiple representations at a
Visia so this is one thing that
complicates variant matching just a
normal scale but we have an additional
problem in terms of thinking about how
we intersect clinic
historical clinical data with the new
genomics data that we're generating now
and I'll use the example that should be
well known to most people which is a
delta f 508 variant and cftr so in this
graphic we have the cftr gene and the
Delta F 508 and the bottom and if we
look at this more closely we can see for
there are two potential mechanisms that
would mediate this change you could look
at deleting this TCT or this ctt and if
we look in DB snip what we find is both
representations so we see this RS ID is
associated with the clinical information
and the clinvar record but what's
moderately surprising here is there's no
allele frequency information associated
with this variant which is surprising is
you would expect to find this variant
within the thousand genomes data as the
Delta F 508 is a founder mutation and is
at a very low frequency of the normal
population but if we look more closely
in vb student we do see a representation
now we see the TCT variant as reported
by thousand genome so we actually can
get the allele frequency but none of the
clinical information is associated with
this and if you want to annotate this
variability you'd really want both the
allele frequency information as well as
any information known about the package
in the city or information from clinvar
to show you this on a more genome sort
of scale here we have a similar
representation to what I've been showing
you before so here's the chromosome
assembly this is the gene annotation
here is our clinvar track and here is
our DD snipped track and so what we can
see this guy right here is our thousand
genomes version of our beriant and this
guy right here is our clinton bar
representation of this variant and the
reason for this discrepancy is because
there are different standards in the
genomic world versus the clinical world
and this sort of harkens back to this
day that you know back when most of the
gene based testing was actually
transcript based not genomics pace so I
pointed out earlier that there had been
a time when we did gene Disease
Association really
transcript level and so that standard
developed an ocean where if you had an
insertion deletion variant you would
shift it as far to the right as possible
with respect to the transcript whereas
the VCF standard has developed to be
less shifted with respect to the genome
now I have heard many people say well
can't we just left you know can't we
just right shift VCF but that's not
going to solve the problem because the
hdds standard is with respect to the
transcript and so it's about half your
transcripts are on the plus side and
half your transcripts are on the
negative strand your VCF is going to be
shifted wrong half the time regardless
of what your finger it is so in terms of
thinking about how you integrate this
data you have to take that into account
so that you can really get the best
annotation possible there are other
cases where this gets even more
complicated so here we see a variant
that was reported in 1996 describing
this insertion in the ATM gene and you
know this is somewhat problematic in
fact because I'd be nicer to know what
specific transcript who's used because
it's a very transcriptionally complex
gene luckily this was a paper that
occurred long enough ago where we
actually put sequences in the papers
because that was the speed with which we
can do things back then so I was able to
blast this sequence and and actually
identify where this insertion was this
demonstrates that the reference the
reference sequence has changed because
this was originally reported to be
between exons 40 and 41 and now it's
between exons 38 and 39 but I still
don't know what the exact genetic lesion
leading to this is now about another
hour of curation and digging and our lab
discovered that the actual Legion that
causes this is a c2g change activating a
cryptic splice site causing insertion of
this intronic sequence into the
transcript and so I think this really
underscores the importance of really
making sure that we archive our variance
at the genomic level so that we can do
robust mapping but thus underscore the
importance of also trying to retain
information about the transcript
interpretation because this leads to
mechanism
I don't think there's a really a process
that I'm aware of that would be able to
take this change and predict that it
would activate a cryptic splice site so
both levels of information are important
but we have to think about standardizing
our representations on genetic sequence
for doing this type of matching in
limitation so in conclusion I'd like to
just remind people about what I talked
about today and that is you know we
really have to think about picking the
assay that's best suited to the address
the question that you have particularly
regardless even if somebody tells you
they're doing a whole genome assay you
really want to be able to define the
genomic intervals they're doing a very
good job on and this is true of whether
it's an exome essay at genome assay or a
panel essay because you also want to be
able to assess the performance of that
essay on the intervals in which you're
interested and we really have a lot of
work as a community to think about how
we really want to store and represent
normalize variants both of the genomic
level and the transcript level for
improved annotation and with that I'm
happy to take any questions
well thank you dr. church for that
informative presentation before we start
the Q&A session at like to remind our
audience that you can submit questions
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button and the
left lower left hand corner of the
presentation window okay and we'll
answer as many questions as we can see
well so far there are no questions so i
guess if if anyone has any questions
please submit them now okay I'm sorry I
your spirit here they are here's a
question from Canada Moorish and her
question is is this region located in a
known segmental duplication I believe
this refers to a previous slide around
slide 47 in the presentation um so I'm
not sure with the round slide 47 um so I
guess it depends on whether the
questioner is referring to the Casey and
one example that I showed where a new
parallel was added or if they're
referring to regions where we are adding
alternate low sighs so I'll try and
answer both of those so with respect to
Casey and one iowa i don't think that
was a region of known segmental
duplication and part of that is actually
related to the fact that our ability to
identify segmental duplications is often
somewhat reference biased although there
are reference independent ways of
identifying these but I don't think this
was something that was really known and
expected by anybody now with respect to
the places where we've added alternate
loci these regions are not exclusively
known to have segmental duplications
asian although we do know that in many
cases where there are large structural
variations there is a very strong
association with segmental duplications
so in some cases where we see readings
where we've had to add alternate website
these are actually complicated by the
fact that there is also segmental
duplications in these regions and so
when you're actually assessing the
alignments it can get complicated
because you know the novel seek that the
so-called novel sequence that you might
be adding by the ultimate low low side
could actually also be added new
paralogs to things that are on the
primary assembly so in many cases these
regions are very complex and it's one of
the reasons that they both need an
alternate sequence representation
because there's a lot of population
diversity there and it's also why many
of them are very difficult to assemble
it to assemble and the in their primary
assembly I okay our next question is
from and I'm going to try this
pronunciation Raja llevarla and ketu and
the Cancer Institute the question is
what is confident levels of variance in
hot spot panels which are available in
market your opinion please an opinion
because I'm not familiar with these
products so I'm sorry I don't think I
can answer your question because I'm not
very familiar with these I would have to
I don't have to know more information
about these hot spot panels or next
question is from Jorge Mendes Rios the
NIH Chennai a ID this question is how
good our sequences in the telomeric
regions so that so that's really quite
variable um we the GRC actually work
very closely with Harold Reichman to try
and complete as many of those as
possible so so some of the regions are
some of the subtelomeric regions are in
relatively good shape and others are
still somewhat roughly you might say and
it also makes a big difference about
whether you're looking at gr CH 37 or gr
CH 38 there were significant
improvements in 38 but one way to get a
good idea about how much you can trust
either they assembly either in the
subtelomeric regions or in other regions
is when you're looking at whatever your
browser of choice is make sure you turn
on that track that lets you see how the
clones were used to build the assembly
because if you look at a region and you
see there are a lot of gaps in the
region that is a huge indication that
there were problems doing the assembly
there and so you might want to take the
order in there with a little bit of a
grain of salt because what the GRC tends
to do is they use the evidence that's
best available at the time to try and
order sequence but if you see a lot of
gaps it typically means that that
evidence might not have been very strong
and so you know if you don't see gaps it
doesn't mean there's not a problem but
if you do see gaps you should definitely
be aware the other source of information
that you can use is that the GRC
releases a track of issues that they're
curating and this is available in all of
the common leaves browser at UCSC and an
ensemble and an NCBI so you can turn
this track on and you can see the
regions that the GRC is actively working
on and maybe why they're working on them
and so that's another way that you can
look to see if a region of the genome
that you are particularly interested in
maybe well assembled or may have
problems
so I think we're about out of time so
I'd like to thank everybody for
participating and and asking the great
questions and i look forward to
hopefully meeting all of you in person
one day thank you all for attending I is
I have a one reminder are actually an
announcement that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing for six
months from today you will receive an
email from lab roots and alerting you
when this webcast will be available to
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues would
may have missed today's event thanks
again and we'll see you next time
goodbye